[Music]
would you ever want to buy your own
planet even if it was just the size of a
house it could be the perfect vacation
spot unbeatable privacy and breathtaking
views what more could you ask for well
before you go signing the mortgage there
are a few things you'd want to consider
like would a tiny planet have air for
you to breathe
could you grow food there and would
there be enough gravity to keep you on
the surface this is what if and here's
what would happen if you lived on a tiny
planet to figure out what life would be
like on a tiny house sized planet you'd
have to find one first but the smallest
planet we've discovered so far kepler
37b is still about the size of our moon
so maybe you're better off looking at an
asteroid instead they're not technically
planets but they can be as small as 10
metres wide so they fit the physical
properties you're looking for but there
are a lot of asteroids out there so how
do you pick the best one to live on the
main asteroid belt in our solar system
orbits the Sun roughly between Mars and
Jupiter
it contains three different types of
asteroids stony carbonaceous and
metallic the kind that you'd be looking
for is carbonaceous because those
asteroids are usually made up of 10
percent water which can be broken down
to oxygen for breathing how about this
one it's about 10 meters wide just the
size you were looking for it almost
seems a little too convenient doesn't it
well that convenience wouldn't last long
once you'd land it on your new tiny
planet you'd realize that the conditions
are a lot different from what you're
used to for starters your feet would
feel a lot heavier than your head
that's because your tiny planets
gravitational force would be so weak
that you would also experience the
feeling of other gravitational forces
pulling you upward the other forces
wouldn't be strong enough to pull you
off the planet but they would result in
you feeling a mild stretching sensation
as they compete with the gravity of your
planet
speaking of gravity you'd also have to
be careful how quickly you move around
on this planet because if you move too
fast you could escape its gravitational
pull every planet has something called
an escape velocity which refers to the
minimum speed an object must have to
escape its gravitational field on a
planet this size the escape velocity
would be five meters per second that
means you could technically leave the
planet by getting a running start and
leaping off a ramp then you should be
floating off into space but assuming
you're not going to try that you're
going to be here for a while and you
should probably start figuring out how
to survive the first thing to worry
about is where are you getting your food
well I hope you like veggies because any
meat is pretty much out of the question
not only would you have to bring some
livestock along with you through space
successfully you'd also have to find
enough room to keep them and grow food
for them and you don't have much room to
begin with for the vegetarian option you
could bring something similar to what
NASA uses on the International Space
Station it's called the vegetable
production system and it's a garden
that's about the size of a piece of
carry-on luggage that can hold six
plants it's specifically designed to
grow plants and vegetables in
microgravity conditions no you wouldn't
have the most exciting menu on your
rocky retreat but at least it would keep
you alive
now before you go trying to figure out
anything else there's something you
might want to see a 2019 study published
in the Astrophysical Journal states that
any planet smaller than 2.7 percent of
Earth's mass would lose its atmosphere
and any liquid water it might have due
to a lack of gravitational force
well even 2.7 percent of Earth's mass is
still double the mass of the moon so
your tiny planet would be without those
two major components for sustaining life
if your planet can't hold an atmosphere
then you wouldn't be able to breathe and
you wouldn't have protection from the
harmful radiation of space so maybe
buying yourself a tiny planet wouldn't
be such a great idea after all
if you want a vacation in space you're
probably better off waiting for space
hotels to be built but that's a story
for another what-if
[Music]